welcome back i think i was rushing that
problem so let me just make it clear
again um so just so you don't get
confused because i was trying to get
under that 10 minute limit but they want
to know what the perimeter of this red
is right that's the that's kind of the
outside of this thing that looks like a
flower or something
and what i'm saying is that the
perimeter of the red part is equivalent
to the sum of the perimeters of the
rectangles of the triangle sorry the sum
of the perimeters of the triangles but
if i were to just take the sum of the
perimeter of the triangle
i would also be i wouldn't just be
getting the red part i'd also be getting
in
these parts right because those are
parts of the perimeters of the triangles
so if i want just the red part i
subtract out
this what i just drew in blue
and the blue is the perimeter of that
inside square and the perimeter of the
inside square is 9 plus 9 plus 9 plus 9
or 36
so i just take the perimeter of all four
triangles
each of them has a perimeter of 30. so
together they have a perimeter of 120
and i subtract out the perimeter of the
square inside which has perimeter of 36.
so 120 minus 36
is what 84
right 84 and that's choice d
next problem let me remember that this
is where i ended the last problem okay
next problem problem number 13.
the graph of g of x is shown above
okay i better draw it like because they
want us to
essentially look at the graph and figure
out a value
so at
well let's see it starts at you know
roughly
if i would let's see two
two
four
six
eight
and then we have
two
four
six
eight
and i'll try my best to draw it like
they have so the line starts like
roughly a little bit above
six not even not even up to seven
and then where does it go it goes to
like four oh my god i was using the line
tool
it starts a little bit above six not
even up to seven looks like it about at
one
it starts here and it goes to the point
four comma two it looks like
four comma
two and it goes from four comma two to
six comma three roughly
or maybe even exactly six comma three
and then it looks like it goes to eight
comma eight
eight comma eight is like there roughly
it's about right and then it goes down
to like i don't know almost eleven comma
two
that goes down someplace like that
and they're asking so they're saying
this is the graph of g of x
and they're saying if g of 2 is equal to
k
which of the following could be the
value of g of k
g of k is what
so what could k equal let's figure out g
of 2
so when
x is 2
what is y equal to
well it looks pretty darn close to 5 if
not exactly 5. so k is equal to 5 right
g of 2
is equal to 5 right and they want to
know what g of k is well we figured out
that k is equal to 5 so now we don't
know what g of 5 is
so we go to five we go
up
this is five and then we go pop up up up
up up up up looks pretty close to three
g of five and actually the way they drew
it well actually the way they do it
doesn't look close to three the way they
drew it if you look at where five is it
looks actually less than three it looks
like like two and a half actually
the way they drew it that's why my
drawing is a little off
so if you look down
look look at the x value when x is equal
to 5 you go up to the graph
it looks like the graph value there is
right around two and a half so i should
say this is two and a half
and that is one of the choices b
next problem
problem 14.
if 0
is less than or equal to x which is less
than or equal to eight
and
negative one is less than or equal to y
which is less than or equal to three
which of the following gives the set
of all possible values of x times y
okay so we really just want to figure
out how low can x times y be and how
high times can x times y be
well what's the lowest possible value
for x times y
the lowest possible value of x times y
well if we make y negative
and we make x really big or as big as it
can be if x is 8 and y is negative 1
then that is that is the
that's the lowest value for x times y i
can think of so
x y
is
is going to be
greater than or equal to negative 8
because i i took when you take a
negative number you want the other
number to be as big as possible so you
get a large negative number and it's
going to be less than or equal to
well what's the what's the
what is the
what is the largest number
that i can think of
well if i take 8 and i multiply it times
the large value of y and this is a
positive value then i get 24. so xy is
going to be greater than or equal to
negative 8 and less than or equal to 24.
and that is choice e
and once again how did i get negative
eight this was probably the part that's
not intuitive for you
is because i mean your think might have
been well x the minimum x is zero right
so i'll take zero times any of these so
this is going to be 0
but you can actually get a smaller value
for xy by using negative 1 and 8. so
that's where we got the negative 8 from
next question 15
switch colors 15
let me draw that it looks like a line
there
line there
then there's another line that goes like
that
and then they write that this is
n degrees right there
in the figure above what is the sum in
terms of n
of the degree measures of the four
angles marked with arrows fascinating so
they want to know that plus that
plus that
well let's just do the angle game if
this angle is n well then this angle is
n
right
what is what is let me switch colors
what is this angle here
well it's supple it's supplementary to n
so this is 180
this is 180 minus n
and so is this this is also 180
minus n
and so what are
what are these what's the sum of these
two angles
all right let me call this let me call
this a
b
what's the sum of a plus b well we know
that a plus b
plus this angle plus 180
minus n
is equal to
180 right because they're all in the
same triangle
so a plus b
is equal
to 180
minus 180
plus n i just took this and
subtracted 180 and added n to both sides
this cancels out so you get a plus b is
equal to n
and similarly if you had c if this were
c and d you could do the same thing c
plus d plus this angle
minus n is equal to 180 because they're
all in the same triangle
subtract 180 from both sides and then
add n to both sides you get c plus d is
equal to n
so if you want to know what a plus b
plus c plus d is
c plus d
is
a plus b is n
c plus d is n
so the whole thing is going to be n plus
n or 2n
and that is choice b
see if i have time to do problem 16
considering i have a little over under a
minute left
problem 16.
after the first term each term in a
sequence actually this is going to be i
think this will take some explanation so
i'll do 16 in a video by itself i'll see
in the next video